all right as we continue famed Harvard
Law Professor Alan Dershowitz a long
haul for Muller's witch-hunt to come to
an end and now he's even comparing the
Special Counsel investigation to the
tactics of the former Soviet Union
joining us now to explain author of the
new book trumped up how criminalization
of political differences in dangers
democracy you know I noticed you get
attacked but you've been very consistent
on the special counsel and the
criminalization of political differences
oh yeah today we see that Muller
announces that one of the things that
he's going to go after Trump for and
Rosenstein says he can do it is
collusion
now he's inventing a crime there's no
such crimes collusion in the federal
statute you can't just make up crimes
nobody likes collusion if collusion had
occurred and there's no evidence it did
if collision that occurred it would be a
political sin but neither Rosenstein nor
Muller can simply magically make up a
crime and say now collusion is a crime
you want to make collusion a crime in
the future pass the statute it's not on
the books what about the violation of
the special council law that gregg
jarrett was talking about and I think
it's interesting one week after Paul
manna ports home was raided and his poor
wife is thrown in the handcuffs which
wasn't necessary that's typical Andrew
Weissman tactics but what a week after
Rosenstein then authorizes Muller to do
it no there's something very wrong with
that you know the special counsel should
have very narrow
jurisdiction and it should be set out in
advance so everybody can see it and know
it you know the Constitution talks about
ex post facto criminal laws the policies
behind that are fair warning and
constraining the government and the
government when you have a special
prosecutor should know and everybody
should know what he's entitled to look
and what he's not intended to look at
this special prosecutor is gonna look at
everything he's he's beginning to look
at president Trump's personal financial
matters before he was president will he
start looking at the women who were
alleging actions against him where does
it stop we know that the Clinton special
counsel started with whitewater and
ended up with a blue dress and that's
it's wrong weird does jonathan turley a
smart law professor also on the other
side
politically than where I am he made a
good point he thought the the
appointment by the Attorney General of
the prosecutor who burr that actually
helps Trump is gonna move so much faster
I agree with that and first of all
that's what should have happened when
Special Counsel was appointed they
shouldn't have appointed a special
counsel in the beginning they should
have had somebody within the Justice
Department look at it initially look at
the whole issue of Russian involvement
in the election and then if it looked
like there was evidence of crimes that
couldn't be investigated by the Justice
Department
then maybe you think the Attorney
General has a right as what as it right
by doing it this oh I think this time he
has it right now the other problem of
course is Rosenstein I don't know how he
remains on this case he is the major
witness that any decent Trump lawyer
calls he's the guy who wrote the memo
the first question you want to ask him
if there's an obstruction of justice
investigation is how can they be
obstruct our office yeah you wrote the
memo authorizes the only fire any OSI in
the case he renewed the FISA application
and then he appointed Muller
so he's conflicted on a thousand
different ways all right here's where we
disagree I argue that Hillary Clinton
violated 18 USC 793 she didn't want
congressional oversight mishandling of
classified information then she'd
subpoenaed emails are deleted 33,000
then acid washing the hard drive and
then beating up your book your devices
and as a result of that she lost the
election because he investigated it and
said there was no crime but what she did
was careless don't you think that that's
the appropriate way to deal what is it
here my defense attorney I love you but
is it careless when you acid wash or
hard drive
delete subpoenaed emails and beat the
crap out of your blackberry well she
didn't do that of course other people
did it and the question is is that a
short rope really was she appropriately
investigated and was the decision a
correct one not to proceed criminal
endeavors of no lisa page and Peter
struck and James Comey and Andrew McCabe
and Loretta Lynch meeting bill on the
tarmac I don't like a fix I don't like
any of that I think Bill Clinton made a
terrible mistake having that meeting
because that's what led to the Attorney
General
accusing herself leading to Comey taking
over the investigation leading last what
statement he made leading to her losing
often call me writing the exoneration
months before they interview her or 17
other key witness it's worth looking
into it's worth I was like it fixes and
out of Special Counsel but it's worth
looking into again may be a political
sin but not a federal crime okay but if
you write an exoneration before an
invest not a crime it sounds like the
fix is it that would be obstruction
wouldn't it no but you first of all I
don't think the Attorney General can
obstruct justice by talking about the
Attorney General talk about the FBI
director yeah it's a stretch and I don't
want to stretch the criminal law let's
you've exposed it let the people judge
let the public judge
I don't think appointing another special
counsel makes up for the mistake of
appointing the first special count Thank
You professor